foreign
you
okay being the appointed hour i i'm
going to start
we
did kind of all call here on our
remaining bills because of time
so i apologize if we might
uh keep some people here
inadvertently but
last time i scheduled bills with
intervals
we wasted the whole day and
this way at least we're going to get it
done
because the the foot's on the neck to
get things done just so you'll know
i want to start we had a request to
start with
hb
so i'll open the work session on house
bill 1587.
i know the sponsor is here and if you'd
like to say make a couple of comments
here so here's my plan on this bill
we do have an amendment
uh
which basically changes the amount from
56 million to 28 million
i i plan to have that amendment
voted on today and then recess this work
session until friday at 1.
because right now the
leadership's trying to amass how much
money are coming through from the
different finance departments
for this
this year
so we we don't know i'm meeting at four
o'clock this afternoon with a speaker on
these topics so
by friday at one o'clock we should have
a resolve
and uh we may have another amendment i'm
not sure
but we're we're in the state of studied
flux right now
so does anybody have any comments on
1587 they'd like to make one way or the
other
please
thank you mr chair and thank you for
members of the committee for the record
i'm representative steve pearson
rockingham district six
which encompasses
dairy
not having that amendment in front of me
i would really like to see what that
looks like
all it does is change the amount
right now the amount is is a 55 million
and all it does is take it to 28 million
that's the only thing the amendment does
is that correct mike
yes the bill is introduced
do you have it available i do we want
why don't you pass it out because the
sponsors ask the question so we can
answer that question so um
for a mona for just the sake of
technicality i'm the dr i'm actually the
drafter
of this and representative pratt filed
it oh okay but i wrote it so and you
know how that goes right i mean
but
thank you
one just one of the things i wanted to
touch upon
and i'm certainly by no means here to
steal anyone's thunder
is the situation
that that we're facing right now has
changed in the last seven days
you know surprisingly
and unfortunately it has gotten
substantially worse
not better okay
as i mentioned in my floor speech
when we when this was passed as a
policy piece
then at the time the national guard was
being used to augment the prison
staffing
crisis they have been removed from the
prison system
so now the the department of corrections
can't even rely on the backfilling of
national guard troops
and and i
i'm not entirely sure how disastrous
this is going to be for them i know that
these troops barely got them to tread
water so
you know one of the things that
having been in the emergency services in
new hampshire for 20 years is
there are situations that are occurring
today that if someone told me 20 years
ago i would have told them they were out
of their minds
you know i
as a as a real world example i tested
for manchester fire in 2001
with 400 people
today
we have as matter they don't not only do
they have no one to pick from they've
offered the job a job to five people and
five people have said no
that hasn't happened in the 165 year
history of the manchester fire
department
manchester police is now doing
recruiting as far west as ohio
and that again that's something that was
never even fathomed
10 years ago
so we really truly do have a recruitment
and retention problem in new hampshire
and you know one of the things that
i found acceptable you know back in the
day was that you know what no one ever
gets rich being a civil servant right
they shouldn't
but on the flip side of that there's
there's something at the other end
and
the changes that occurred back in in
um that were done with no public hearing
they were slipped into a trailer bill
there was some warning actually one of
the fellas that did some of the warning
was in this room who warned them back
then and said look there's going to be
some consequences to this
and he was laughed at and here we are
now so
um you know i won't get into any other
policy part of it you guys are all on
the floor of the house i mean a veto
proof majority is a is a glowing example
of of the recognition of the situation
we're in right now so
i appreciate the the
this group you know holding a work
session and looking this over and really
taking the deep dive that's necessary to
to make this work
but i just really can't emphasize enough
the situation that we're in in new
hampshire is is getting worse not better
so i thank you folks for your time
certainly thank you
and i would i would comment that
one of the
terms that kind of
i learned by going through this is
terminally funded
which means it is going to fund this for
the
terminal periods of all employees
involved
that means going to solve the problem
forever
my my uh attitude right now based on
available funds is let's put a band-aid
on it and
kick it down the road a bit because i
don't know that we can afford 56 million
dollars right now
anybody else want to comment on yes sir
good morning representative mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is arthur beaudry i represent
the new hampshire state permanent
firefighters retirement association i'm
a retired captain from the manchester
fire department and a past member of the
new hampshire retirement system board of
trustees and i'm here today to speak in
favor of house bill 1587.
first and foremost i would like to thank
the sponsors for introducing this bill
in 2011 the legislature made some
additional changes to the definition of
earnable compensation they used the term
vested status instead of when a member
commences service on the date of the
changes
what they did what they did was create a
six-tier system the members who were
vested members in various stages of
vesting and the members who had
commenced service
prior to these changes the legislature
had made changes prospectively and not
retroactively i believe this was the
first time that a benefit reduction was
retroactive
although the courts have ruled it is
legal to make these changes morally and
ethically is it right when an employer
starts his or her employment they are
there are there is an expectation that
the benefits offered when hired will be
there when they retire
when the legislature made these changes
i truly believe that most of them didn't
know or understand the long-term effects
of the changes and if they had would
have considered implementing them for
future hires only
when the state downshifted the
obligation to the cities and towns to
pay the 35 percent of the retirement
cost and the retroactive changes to the
benef pension benefits the employee was
affected both at the bargaining table
and in their pensions
these changes made it extremely
difficult for local communities to offer
a competitive
company compensation package to attract
new employees and retain existing
employees
past legislative changes have proven to
be beneficial to the long-term viability
of the new hampshire retirement system
but at what cost to the employee
the committee had
this committee heard testimony last week
on house bill 1417 where the speaker
explained
they did
what they did it was to balance what
they did was to balance the budget the
speaker testified that the finance
committee reduced benefits and increased
employee contribution rates in the
attempt to balance the budget these
changes to the plan benef benefits allow
the local employer rates to go down
is this just a shift in benefit
obligation from the employer to the
employee
under section 18 b average final
compensation shall mean for the purposes
of inclusion
in this calculation the average
percentage of compensation paid in
excess of the full base rate of
compensation in the highest five years
shall not exceed the average percentage
of compensation paid in the in excess of
the full base rate of compensation over
all the members years of service on or
after june 1st 2012 but excluding the
highest 12 years five years
you can see you you you can't have an
average over a member's years of service
without including the members highest
five years of service in the calculation
using the term over the members years of
all the members years of service is just
that
excluding any part of the member service
in the calculations would no longer be
the members years
all the members years of service
this is taxation with our representation
we ask that
you support the language submitted in
house bill 1587 by doing so will truly
allow all the members years of service
to be calculated
again we asked that the committee
support
the passage of house bill 1587 and
reinstate the benefits expected by the
employees when they were hired
i handed out
a
spreadsheet and on that basically shows
the difference from
prior to 2011 the first column is
prior to 2011 and i try to make make it
as simple simple as we could um where
you could see how somebody could spike
their pension if they worked a lot of
overtime in their last five years um
those five years were
the only years that were included in the
calculations for their pensions so you
can see somebody that uh firefighter a
worked no overtime at all firefighter b
worked
overtime in their last five years this
is prior to 2011
so one pension would be 20 000 the other
pension would be 25 000 because they
included all the years of service
when you look at
the line that says after
july 1 2021 both employee and employers
paid into the retirement system for
firefighter b
uh uh then firefighter a
more into for firefighter a than
firefighter b but both firefighters
received the same pension um because
they eliminated the highest five years i
put it the last five but those five
highest years could be anywhere in this
calculation and it would the results
would be the same so even though the
employer and the employee paid into the
system um on the additional dollars for
uh
for firefighter b the results um was the
same for the as firefighter eight who
didn't pay any additional making any
additional contributions
and then if you look at the proposed
changes um
that uh firefighter b would receive
roughly 20 of his average annual
earnings over the uh members years of
service so if you calculate it all
included the five years it's it's still
not like it was prior to july 1 20
uh 2011 but at least they're getting
some compensation for the years of
service um uh and i mean the amount of
money they put in for those years of
service and their pension would go to 21
000 a year so it eliminates the real
spiking it's but it still doesn't give
that individual the benefit back
prior to 2011 if i'm making myself clear
and i will answer any questions
any questions from the board
mr boater could you if you have your
written testimony can can the clerk have
it for to put it in the file i can thank
you
thank you
anyone else like to speak on 1587
yes sir
good morning uh for the record my name
is brian rill i'm the president of the
professional firefighters of new
hampshire uh and i'm a fire captain in
portsmouth
uh i just excuse could you spell your
last name yes real r-y-l-l
you're welcome
um i'm not gonna uh repeat a lot of the
things that you've already heard i know
you have a lot a lot to get after this
morning i just wanted to offer
a little bit more context on why this
bill
is important to firefighters here in new
hampshire
[Music]
it was mentioned earlier some of the
recruitment and retention issues that
we're having
and
as part of that i'd like to share with
you
some numbers um representative pearson
had mentioned uh what was going on in
manchester i can tell you that that's a
statewide issue
uh and that began um there's a clear
delineation from the the changes in 2011
to the retirement system
just prior to that in 2010
there were approximately 550 candidates
annually that were taking the
state entrance exam to become a
firefighter
those numbers
clearly started trending downward uh
once the changes were made in 2011
and now we're seeing
somewhere around one 150 to 200
candidates testing every year
in addition to that what what
municipalities are seeing statewide is
an increase in call volume uh
you know
take portsmouth for instance
they continue to build up um the the
call volume increases they're bringing
more people into the city uh and and the
calls are becoming um
more drastic right we're just we're
dealing with a global pandemic obviously
um the opioid crisis is is another big
example of of the ever-changing dynamics
of the job
unfortunately
when they're trying to to staff these
positions they're creating new positions
because the the staffing needs to meet
uh what's going on in the municipality
as far as call volume
unfortunately they're
unable to fill these positions because
of
um
a lot of things like the retirement
system that have changed
that has changed the members benefit
over over time so we're seeing um for
every person that we're hiring in
in the state of new hampshire we're
seeing two vacancies which is a
significant problem in fact last april
the the state hit an all-time low with
the number of candidates that took the
the test uh in in that quarter was 39
candidates
for hundreds of open positions
throughout the state
um it's it's a significant problem and i
think it because you can draw the
correlation to what happened to the
retirement system in 2011 it's one that
we realize that that's where the fix
needs to start
the department of safety has recognized
this to be an issue they're working to
develop
recruitment and retention
coordinator recruitment and retention
committees
they've identified this to be a
significant problem too throughout the
state
and
one that we need to to work towards to
fix i can tell you that we
surveyed our members
um throughout the state to the point
that this has no longer become anecdotal
members that have left the job have told
us um in no uncertain terms that it's
because of what happened to the
retirement system in 2011
members that are considering leaving the
job have told us the same
and so i i have serious concerns over
what the fire service looks like over
the next 10 years if we don't work
towards a fix today
um
with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
but i i appreciate all your work on this
and thank you for putting some thought
into it i have one question in your
opinion does 1587
help fix the issue
yes the short answer is yes
what i can tell you is we've gone
through
fire departments throughout the state
and we've talked to them about this
issue
i can tell you that with all the changes
that occurred to the retirement system
back in 2011 this was one of the issues
that
wasn't one of the glaring issues because
there were so many other bigger nastier
changes
to the retirement system this was one
that kind of got lost in the shuffle
right
but now that we've drawn so much
attention to it we've educated our
members on it i can tell you
firefighters and and i'm certain that
the police officers can speak the same
and corrections can do so
they're not happy because they feel like
they were bamboozled to some degree um
this one this one was kind of hidden uh
buried deep in the retirement language
that um you know it takes some time to
dig up and and really see what's
happening here but now these
firefighters are realizing they're
paying 11.8 percent on every single
dollar that they earn to the retirement
system and they're not seeing that money
uh at the end of the day or at the end
of their careers rather
so i do i i
i would be lying to you if i sat up here
and i told you i think that this is
this is the silver bullet fix
everything's going to be grand after
this but i do think that it is a
significant step
in a in a good direction towards
maintaining and and recruiting
firefighters throughout the state of new
hampshire okay thank you any other
questions
yes
thank you and thank you for all that you
do certainly not easy and i appreciate
it and your testimony today
when recruiting
or when discussing with new hires the
retirement system here they are brand
new to the scene
what is the i guess elevator speech in
other words the summarize summary you
would give a brand new person about the
retirement system and the benefits
offered thereof upon their joining
that's a great question um i can tell
you it
more than likely it varies from
department to department um
what i can tell you is when i started
about 16 years ago the pitch was that to
be a public servant in the state of new
hampshire
you worked hard the money wasn't you
weren't going to get rich off of it but
at the end of your career you were going
to have a thoughtful pension that was
going to be worth all the time and
dedication that you put in towards a
career in public service
i can tell you now
we're unable to make that pitch
because of what the system is now
um i will tell you
they're still
i i'm not going to tell you your
retirement at the end of your career is
horrible now i i don't think that that's
fair to say but i can certainly say it's
not a huge selling point for new
candidates coming on now to let them
know that um you know you may come in at
45 000 a year base salary but if you
work hard and you put in 25 years
you're going to have a good pension and
so i can tell you representative at this
point we're not really using that much
as a selling point
all set any other questions yes
representative goalie
thank you mr chair just briefly because
sitting on edna i heard a lot of this
testimony but i just want to reiterate
that
from what we hear with the shortage
in
the trouble of getting new recruits into
the system
relies on overtime to fill those missing
positions
and that overtime that
these employees are paying into the
retirement system on and end up being
their best years of their career while
they're being forced into that overtime
is it not true that they will not see a
benefit for those extra hours paid
correct thank you for the question uh
representative yes so many of our
members are being forced now to work
overtime to cover these vacant positions
um
and
because at the end of the day we can't
have
fire trucks with no firefighters on them
we can't have police cars with no police
officers in them and we can't have
prisons with no corrections officers so
these folks are being forced in to work
in many cases
putting in hundreds of hours
of mandatory overtime away from their
families away from their homes and
at the end of the the story
these
the the percentages that they're paying
on all this overtime towards a
retirement system they're not seeing in
their calculation at the end of their
careers
okay and i'll ask you again do this 1587
start to unravel that problem yes okay
any other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
anyone else yes sir
thank you mr chairman
my name is michael gear g-e-h-a
i'm sorry
g-e-h-a
michael i'm the president of the new
hampshire police association and i'm
here today to convey our support for
house bill
1587.
you have heard from others who spoke
before me as to what this bill does
i want to take just a few minutes to
explain to you why this bill is so
important to law enforcement throughout
our state
first let me say that 10 years ago when
numerous changes were made to the
state's retirement program it was
impossible to anticipate the
circumstances that would develop like we
have today
but some of those changes laid the
foundation for hiring and retention
problems by altering provisions and
benefits that had been agreed to when
some members were hired fast forward to
2022 the state of new hampshire and just
about every city and town are facing
serious employment challenges in the
public safety area especially law
enforcement
our state have dozens of unfilled
positions and local communities are
finding the applicant pool to be
extremely tight with that cities and
towns are competing against each other
for not only the limited number of new
hires but in retaining existing
personnel competition from other states
the private sector and in some cases
outright burnout are adding to this very
concerning public safety problem
i want you to know that there is a very
concerning out of the ordinary trend
developing the number of employees who
are leaving before they reach their 20
or 25 years is very real
that is something none of us could have
contemplated just a few years ago
the one tool that can help address this
problem is strengthening the retirement
benefits so there is incentive to stay
for the full term
we believe hb
is the kind of tool that will help in
retaining those individuals who might be
thinking about leaving early and quite
frankly the economics makes sense local
communities spend an average about 50
000 or more to train certify and equip
each new police officer
each time one
each time one leaves the new higher
training costs hit local budgets and
that's if the local community can even
find new hires
we are very fortunate in this state to
have such a dedicated skilled and
qualified group of law enforcement
officers but the challenges are there
for the future
i ask you to think hard about this
potential crisis and to act before it
gets worse we all need to do everything
possible to encourage these individuals
to work their full pre-retirement terms
that's good for the safety of our
citizens in every community keep in mind
being a police officer today is a
challenging stressful job
it is a noble profession it's something
that i truly love but every minute on
the job is filled with safety concerns
house bill 1587 will help our state and
local communities in their recruitment
and retention of qualified police
officers i urge you to support this bill
thank you
thank you any questions
yes representative hatch
thank you sir
you got to turn your mic
i hate these things um
i don't know if you have this
information or not but i think it's
germaine do you have a percentage of
personnel that
left the department early say in 2010
prior to this
as compared to what leaves early now i
recognize the problem even within my
community but do you have some sort of
numbers that correlates this or not i
don't have an accurate number sir but
however every department has those
numbers that we can
possibly retrieve um there is there is i
hear it all the time a lot of people
that have 10 years or less on the on the
job they're leaving for the private
sector
if if that was easily obtained that
would be interesting we'll try to do
that yeah thank you
thank you mr g
okay mr gear could you have your
testimony can we put it in the file
please absolutely okay i actually made a
couple copies good
as i stated before is our intention to
help
solve this problem the question is
how
much can we solve in this particular
bill i'd entertain a motion for the
amendment or do i have any questions on
amendment basically
it's the it's the basic bill changing
the dollar amount
is that correct mr hoffman
i'm being videotaped now so i want to
make sure i'm saying right
directed towards uh representative
goalie you sat on the policy committee
could you tell me what the vote was or
to support the legislation as as it's
been proposed
i can look it up real quick
uh 12 to 6 12 to 6 otp 12 6.
anybody else want to come yes mike
okay
sure
we'll take all the help we can get
and i'll have read this by friday
further comment can i yes
i'm very sympathetic to the bill
and um
i think we should do
what we can do
but i know that we don't have the money
to do a hundred percent of it and i
think uh
this amendment is a step forward
to get us started and
if emotion is an honor i'd like to move
that we accept this amendment
okay the amendment is 107 4h second okay
motion made and seconded
why don't we do a show of hands i don't
think we need a roll call for this one
all those in favor of the amendment
all those opposed
okay the amendment passes four to three
okay i'm going to close the hearing on
1587.
oh yes
i'll reopen it
and recess it till friday at 1.
now we'll close the hearing
okay
we can do it right at the beginning
we're going to have three bills on
friday
okay
it's tough to know where the
preponderance of people are here for
so we'll just we'll take it off the we
continued
uh 15 35 until recessed until today so
i'll open the hearing on 1535
the cost of living adjustments
anybody want to make a comment on
1535 yes ma'am
i know you got to punch the butt you got
to push the button push the button there
we go okay
for the record um my name is karen irwin
and i am from the town of hopkinton i'm
sorry
did
please sure
karen k-a-r-e-n irwin i-r-w-i-n
i did hand you in a letter um earlier
and i did send it out electronically
to several but you should have a letter
in front of you
i'm going to speak to some of what i've
said here
and
this is regarding the cost of living
adjustments
for the state retirees
when this hearing was opened on this
bill it went in as being a reoccurring
cola
for all it ended up being amended to be
a one-time caller for those that were
going to be
five years out of retirement had 60
months in before july 1st 2017.
it was
going to be
pre-funded or terminally funded
and that was
amended by
representative carol mcguire in edna
that bill got passed 17 to 2
and by voice vote on the floor
um
so i'm going to
give you some facts in history here we
did a like
cola
in 2019
basically the same kind of thing
this one is 1.5 as well
and it's on the first 30 000 per year
what i could find from the last delineal
retirement commission report was that
that in 2017 we had nearly 48 000 public
employees that were active contributing
plan members that year the trust paid
706.3 million in pension benefits to
more than 35 000 retirees and
beneficiaries making nhrs one of the
largest payrolls
the state's largest payroll the average
benefits
of with average benefits of 20 thousand
so if you equate the one point five
times the average of twenty thousand
it's only three hundred dollars per year
for each employee's cola
that amount i
from testimony i had heard
because the fiscal note wasn't initially
done that way
it was estimated that in that particular
population five years out we had about
22 thousand
retirees
so that calculation is
six million six hundred thousand dollars
per year
all you know assumptions estimates aside
so what i
went and did on the back page here
is i kind of tried to show you
and that is a spreadsheet
tried to show you
we're starting out with a terminally
funded number of 79 million
and if you know basically if you divide
the 79 million by
six million six hundred thousand you get
twelve years
that would cover 12 years of people's
pension what i
i mean cola
what i hope
that you would um consider is on either
of these funding mechanisms that are
being terminally funded that you think
about putting
a requirement in the legislation
that
creates kind of a special fund so you
can see and that they would get interest
on that balance
so you would get at least the assumed
rate of return which is 6.75
percent right now
um
you know on that balance and that's what
i did in this spreadsheet is i rolled
forward that amount from year to year
adding back you know an assumed rate of
return is met every year which it isn't
always but um
but it
it has been on average
met more
than it has not been hit
so
i guess what i'm asking
you guys to do is to pass this bill
pre-funded in some
manner
to put a requirement in to create the
special cola fund
and to
and for the assumed rate of return or
whatever
is the lowest on a state employee
retiree account
if the return like in 2020 is 1.1
percent that's what we get into our
account
if it's 6.75
i'm sorry if it's higher like 29.6 likes
last year
then
we get 6.75
in our account
because these employees are five years
out i can tell you from my own numbers
that before i exhaust my personal
account
i'm eight years out for my pension and
any cola that we would add which is
minor and so you have three years of
roughly three years depending on how far
people are if they're between five and
eight
they would have some of this money would
be paid out of their account first and
so it won't be coming out of the corpus
of this account it would be coming out
of their personal retirement accounts
because that's how it it works until you
exhaust all your funding in your
personal account it doesn't come out of
the corpus of the fund
so
i hope you'd consider because
that was a pretty high number but i can
hear what you're doing with the other
bill so i hope you consider at least
partially funding this one if not
totally funding the 79 million i think
that would be a step in the right
direction
and
it's much needed it has we haven't had a
regular kohler we need to create a
mechanism
so that we can you know
have those changes somewhere along the
way that we can we made huge returns in
the last so if you look down further
in my letter i quote again at the close
of the fiscal year the retirement
system's net position held in trust was
11.57
billion an increase of approximately
2.44 billion over the prior year an
all-time high for the system
additionally it was stated that nhrs
realized a
209.4 sorry not 29.6
return on investments in the fiscal year
ending june 30th 21 well above
the retirement's assumed rate of return
of 6.75 and the highest one-year return
in more than 30 years it was important
to note that these investment returns
are for a single year and we need to be
considered in the context of portfolios
performance over time
and compared to the assumed rate of
return the 3 5 10 20 and 25 year return
periods
were 11.4 11.3 9.3 7.2 and 7.9
respectively
all returns are net of fees as you can
see none of these accumulated returns
even out to
25 years
your return are lower than 6.75
we had a factor you know at the time
this bill was proposed
was that local government center and
individuals were against it even though
it was modest because they just couldn't
support any more impact
to
to their percentages they pay in locally
that's not the case here you know and so
they were supportive of the bill as long
as they'd have to pay for it in their
rates and so
i do hope
that um
that you will consider
funding this or you know and with the
same kind of premise as what you just
passed a little while ago
and
and i hope you consider that
any questions
representative leishman
thanks mr chairman on friday there was
some discussion about an amendment to
bring this from 12 to
somewhere in between is that still
i do have an amendment
okay a rather kludgy amendment now that
there's more details which will have to
be amended i'm i'm sure
the idea was to try to do what we can in
the current
year yeah uh
but it wouldn't be a one-time thing
it would be
go into their pension as a cola like
they would i'm sorry yeah well why don't
you pass pass out the amendment because
i think we'll probably have to amend the
amendment then okay
but the idea is we
concur with the concept
uh it's the the dollars are a little
of a stretch
yeah
uh so this amendment basically
makes it a
a cola for the current biennium
and i use i use i pull the number out of
the air quite honestly
eight million dollars
i wasn't off you said it'd be six point
six at one well that's what i had for
facts so your facts are better than my
facts
that's what i could pull from reports
that's the most recent information i
could pull which is the average of 20
and i heard
the number 22 000 people so it's pretty
easy to do those numbers then
and so
this works out to about 340
an individual
if you yeah it would be more than one
point yeah you wouldn't need eight
million it would it would depend on what
your base is
uh what what the percentage would be i
did it the other way around if we do it
from saying it's going to be one and a
half percent cola
based on the dollars then it's 6.6
million rather than eight
th
and we can fix that whatever makes the
most sense yeah because this is me
making it up
yeah instead yeah it's a considered a
one-time cola in this bill still but
it's meant to go into the base
going forward
so that's where the bigger dollars come
in
and i guess what i'm saying on my
spreadsheet is we don't need quite that
much money but
um you know from what i can see because
these people aren't increasing they've
retired for five years
you know and
and so i think if we add that one factor
of
making it a special count
and then adding the you know the assumed
rate of return added every year this
money sits there that will be a huge
gain on both of these actions you know
and i don't know if you have to put it
in legislation to do that but i think
you would but i don't know that and um
and i do think that's an important
difference so
um
if i was to make an amendment to this i
would say it's not just um
a one-time it's a cola that we're gonna
try to fund
going in the future so i would change
something to that effect so that
they will get it into the corpus of
their fun and we should
if we
doubled that i would think we would have
enough money to keep us going for a
while
i don't know if you can do that or maybe
i don't know but um
i think what you would see in that
reporting is you would see if they added
the interest that it it negates some of
the payments and it might not be as high
as we think and we would know more
information going forward because i do
like the idea that we
pre-fund some of these expenses in the
future
and so i think that will be
really helpful
too other questions
thank you yeah thank you
and could you do you have a copy for a
letter uh yeah
you do yeah i handed it
all right out so i want to make sure
it's in the file
thank you
yes sir
thank you mr chairman again for the
record my name is arthur beaudry i
represent the new hampshire state
permanent firefighters retirement
association
um i am a captain a retired captain of
manchester fire department and i was on
the retirement system
as a board of trustee um i'm glad we got
to see this amendment
before you
adjourn today
i respect what you're doing and i know
there's only limited funds to give
cost of living raises but the concern i
have with the amendment is b
and what you're stating is you have
anybody that makes over thirty thousand
dollars would get nothing um where at
least in the past
the bill that's written um
everybody would get something up to
their first thirty thousand dollars so
if i made thirty thousand one dollar i
get i wouldn't receive any stipend um if
that could be changed to um
uh include everybody
then i can understand what you would try
to do and actually would be beneficial
to some of the lower income people as i
testified last week
that
i
i'll give you the number of people that
make less than 23 000
um it was a substantial number um
that make less than 20 it's uh 64 make
less than 25 000 so if you're gonna give
them 340
that that's actually more than a one and
a half percent raise which would be
beneficial to them because they're lower
income
earners but to eliminate anybody that's
making over the 30 000 i think you're
going to be hurting a lot of people out
there that are right in that fringe
so if that could be amended to the first
thirty thousand the first thirty
thousand correct
and i would answer any questions
any any questions
thank you thank you
anybody else like to speak on this
bill yes sir
thank you mr chair uh for the record
marty carlin from the new hampshire
retirement system that's k-a-r-l-o-n
retirement system has no position on the
original bill or this amendment i just
uh for informational purposes i just
wanted to come up um
and share a couple of points um
the
the at your request through the lba we
we ran the numbers on
an amendment with anyone who made less
than 30 000 who was retired more than
five years and that that's approximately
23 500 individuals receiving a benefit
right now so a one-time payment you just
be you know
multiplying the dollar amount of what
you want to pay by x you know to get
that to get the bottom line um to mr
beaudry's point uh the original bill was
for anyone who was retired um prior to
july july 1st of 17 or earlier and there
i don't have an exact number on that
today but that that was somewhere
between you know 29 500 and 330 000
people i can
send that over uh to lba okay if you're
interested in expanding it you know
again you just you'll be tying the
number by the benefit
and um as a technical matter on the
amendment and i don't have language in
front of me because i hadn't seen the
amendment but if i could
propose the committee to consider
another section just uh as it's got an
effective date of july 1 of 22 if it
passes
and talking to um the folks in the the
member side and on the data processing
side i
we wouldn't be able to you know make
that payment right away because there's
a lot of programming to
pull that together so if i could um send
over some language about you know
this payment will be issued as soon as
administratively practicable no later
than acts so you know there's a there's
a drop dead day but we want to make sure
we get all that program correct
i think the 18 one we got out like right
at the end of august might be a little
bit longer this year we've got more
projects but you know get it out sooner
but um
if you would send that language that
would be helpful all right and that's
all i had but i'd be glad to answer any
questions i would be interested in the
in the if we
modify this to be the first 30 000 not
just those making less than 30 thousand
what would how many people would that be
sure thing
if you could do that
that's what the intention of this was to
get going down the road so we're going
to revisit this on friday okay okay
thank you thank you
i feel like we're making progress you
got to put a tick on the wheel but
you know we're getting there
any other comments
any amount comments from the board on
the amendment
yes
um it looks to me like we're talking 29
to 30 000 people
uh for the full
full amount
that we'd be uh
we'd be reducing them of the overall
amount by like
and i think the people on the lower end
are the ones that really need that money
so
i think the way it's written
uh helps the people on the lower end of
the scale
so make it just for people earning less
than thirty thousand dollars annually
that's the way it's written now i don't
i don't see the need to change it
represent alicia
uh thanks mr chairman i appreciate your
efforts to
provide some additional benefit
through a cola but i do have a question
and again maybe uh
representative goalie can help me with
this
1.5
or 340 dollars as an average
i hate to say it seems pretty uh
insignificant or poor i guess would be a
better
do you know where that one pers 1.5
percent came from because i think social
security went up greater than that this
year
yeah
i i'm not 100 sure but i i believe you
know it was looking at what we could
afford as a state going forward to help
out these individuals and this was going
to be something that was going to be
when we looked at it and
it was put together by chairman mcguire
was by terminally funding it was to make
sure that it stayed with them because
as we know the last call we gave them
are
stipend we should call it
um they hadn't received anything since
then so now they continue to fall back
because their pay hasn't gone up where
this was looking to
fund it going forward so that they would
have have that money and they wouldn't
lose it and fall behind continue to fall
behind as inflation increases
um
so you know i think it was just looking
at a number that we could do something
to try and help out going forward and
that was um
17 to two out of committee and it was a
voice vote on the house floor for this
proposal
and then i will say that
it was for
the thirty thousand first thirty
thousand on all individuals going back
to that that if you made 30 000 plus one
dollar you get nothing and that was i
mean those folks are still struggling at
that end right there okay
well the concept of this amendment
is to
not spend 80 million dollars
uh that we don't have
it's to make a cola for the current
current biennium
uh i know we're going to have to revisit
it
uh and we'll do that
by friday at 1.
but i would appreciate a motion on
amendment
1073 so we can at least
get the concept of a of a current year
cola on the deck mr chairman
um so so move that motion okay do you
have a second second for discussion mr
chairman good thank you mr lisa
so i would be
you know certainly being a fiscally
conservative democrat support the idea
of not going out 12 years or 20 years or
whatever and just keeping it for the
existing period
as the amendment states but i would hope
that we would do everyone for the 1.5
percent not just those under the 30
percent okay
so your your
modification to this amendment would be
to make it at 1.5 percent yeah for the
first thirty thousand for the first
thirty thousand
okay
can i do a straw vote on on this because
we have two two options one is to say
people making thirty thousand or less
and the other one is
every everybody but only on the first
thirty thousand
so
just a straw vote if you're if you're in
favor of thirty thousand or less as the
option raise your hand
okay if you're interested in
all
retirees first thirty thousand raise
your hand
okay
all right
then i would call for a show of hands on
the amendment
all those in favor
i think from what we just did we need to
change the amendment before we roll it
in i'm going to change it for friday
okay that's good
um
thank you
okay so all in favor of the of the
amendment
and we're going to
be changed
no as it is now i'm
we have to vote on what we got
but i'm going to change it for friday
mr chair if i may just for a procedural
manner um can we not
introduce this as is because it is going
to be changed just do it friday
that's fine the simple dutchman i mean
i just wanted to get the concept of it's
a current year coal only and we're not
going to solve the problem forever
uh so
i agree with that mr chairman okay then
we'll
we will
suspend a vote on this and we i will
recess this hearing this work session
until one o'clock on friday thanks
okay i think we have uh several
individuals here for
custodial interrogation
so i would open the work session on
1540.
do we have anybody would like to speak
to this yes sir
good morning mr chair members of the
committee my name is buzz sher last name
is spelled s-c-h-e-r-r
i am a police commissioner in portsmouth
recently elected and also a professor at
unh law where i've been for 28 years
um
for the record i'm speaking
on my own behalf my opinions do not
reflect those of either the portsmouth
police commission or unh law
i am
in support of
to go directly what it does is it
requires police departments to in some
fashion record
interrogations as defined in the
in the bill
it does not require the recording
if it doesn't fit the definition of
uh
of of the aware of where the location is
that is
uh roadside uh interrogations uh after a
stop for a motor vehicle violation are
not included in this
it is not
[Music]
it's not going to cost police
departments
much if any money because the majority
of police departments at this at this
point including the state police already
record interrogations
um
because the bill says
it can be either an audio
recording or an audio visual recording
whether a police department has video
taping
capability
though i think at this point most do
my understanding
[Music]
even if they don't they can use an audio
recording and
i haven't heard of a police department
even the smallest police departments who
doesn't have the ability to do an audio
recording
if only uh with an iphone but you know i
think uh historically i practiced uh as
a
public defender for 13 years uh back in
as my daughter says in pre-history when
dinosaurs run the earth um from 1980 to
uh even then everybody had uh tape
recording uh mechanisms uh even even a
small department like new durham or uh
ossipee where in the area where i
practiced so i don't think this is any
financial burden whatsoever
it is also i would add
as a matter of policy i think it's good
it's it's good practice for police
departments to do this for their own
protection
you know one of the issues that's
frequently litigated uh in criminal
cases
uh pre-trial is whether the individual
invoked his right to remain silent or
his right to counsel or whether he
waived his miranda rights and uh
criminal defense lawyers litigate that
frequently the extent to which there is
a recording of both the the reading of
miranda and any waiver of miranda and
the entire interrogation it's going to
diminish the ability for any if for
those hearings to even occur let alone
be successful um you know anecdotally
i'm aware of at least two states where
um
the criminal defense lawyer associates
association opposed this bill uh because
they didn't want that to happen
um there are 30 states who have some
version of this bill um so uh we're not
asking uh the state of new hampshire to
go out on a limb and do something nobody
else is doing um
you know as as uh one of the
i i would uh point out i believe uh the
national innocence project
sent um a letter to the committee
uh in support of this bill you know one
of the
most significant reasons that we see
wrongful convictions in the united
states
that is convictions we know are wrongful
because dna evidence has
exculpated the person convicted
somewhere around 27 or 28 of those
involve false confessions it's really a
stunning number if you think about it
and
very often there are people
with uh diminished
intellectual ability
people who english is not their first
language
um or who have some uh mental health
issues
uh and all those groups tend to be more
vulnerable in an interrogation which you
know it's a very
even for the average person a scary
circumstance they tend to be
particularly vulnerable uh and uh you
know that that number is
i've been doing work with the innocence
project since uh
the first part of this century and uh to
this day that number is breathtaking to
me that there's that number of people
um who have been proven to have given
false confessions to confess to
something they didn't do and end up
going to jail
for many years sometimes
so uh this is a
relatively simple bill it's pretty
straightforward it's not going to cost
any money it may cost a little bit for
those departments who choose to upgrade
to audio visual recording
other than that i'm more than willing to
entertain questions
any questions
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you
anyone else wish to speak on 1540
um
going through this
uh one of the areas that i i find a bit
troubling is you if you go to page 2
line 23
it speaks to
presumption of inadmissibility
and my reading of this and you can
correct me if i'm wrong my reading of
this is that if you are
doing recording
and subsequently take any
testimony
unrecorded
it negates you recorded as well as that
which was
not recorded
i knew i was reading it wrong
i wouldn't say wrong but um
that provision uh the baseline of that
provision is if it's not recorded
that
you can show that there was a good
reason for it not being recorded and
therefore uh it will get past that
presumption of inadmissibility so it's
not an absolute it's never going to be
admissible there is a there's a uh
it's it's lack of a better way of
putting it it shifts the burden if it's
unrecorded then you've got to show
there's a good reason for it being
unrecorded now if there's a recorded
confession
um
uh
and the subsequent confession
happened in a set of circumstances that
fit the legislation that is it's not a
you know random comment somewhere where
recording was not possible
then that presumption will apply but but
then again you still have the
opportunity to um to show that there was
a reason for it so
the idea the idea is
we recognize we we don't want to make
the
circumstance of recording confessions
too rigid
we want to appreciate that i would use
an expletive but uh it would be
inappropriate that stuff happens
and um
i think there's flexibility in the bill
to deal with those circumstances so it's
not a rigid
if you don't record it it's not going to
come in be it after an originally
recorded confession or even at the front
end it's uh you gotta it's up to you now
to show us why
uh it didn't get recorded and uh i think
my expectation is courts will be pretty
charitable for reasonable ex reasonable
excuses would it be would it be
inappropriate to put in there that it
could be written and
signed
and not recorded
uh
i think that
starts to get to a situation that's
problematic
for this reason
most of the innocence project wrongful
convictions that involved false
confessions
involved
signed confessions
so it's not it's not a provision that
would give the kind of protection
that this bill is designed to give um to
be very straightforward with the chair
it um
it's
it's a lot easier to
create a circumstance in which someone
is falsely confessing
for whatever reason
and all they have to do is sign it
you know frequently you see some of the
cases out there uh wrongful convictions
you see
uh the police wrote the confession for
the individual and then they signed it
for example in a uh esl circumstance
english's second or third or fourth
language very frequently you see the
police wrote the confession then and
then the individual and they say just
sign this now that we read this and sign
this
so that
that provision
would would
take away the kind of solid protection
that this bill is designed to give
yes
thanks mr chairman i was just curious if
anyone
was in the audience from criminal
justice because i actually find your
take um also problematic as i read this
but
not to put our member to my left on the
spot who is an attorney
if she has any comments but it seems a
little problematic to me
as written right as written
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your description as well i do see that
clause uh as a legislator now talking as
a legislator quite
strict
to the contrary of what you're saying so
definitely some language here to reflect
your comments about there being a
reasonable excuse or a good uh reason
and so forth for the recording not
taking place at the time because words
in this provision like not all any shall
that is rigid
um
two answers one i don't have the
legislation right in front of me so i
can't i can give you a direct comment
thank you
that's page 2 lines 23 through 27. i
have it
and while you're reading that i'll just
make a comment i did talk to the
department of justice ahead of the
criminal division and
his reading on this is that it could
punish a victim
if an officer doesn't follow
this this this and this the victim gets
punished because this is inadmissible so
that that that was their concern with
this
yes sir
uh
i i'm not sure that's well
let me go step by step
um um i was present uh when criminal
justice uh uh uh heard this bill
this concern was not addressed i see
that representative welch is also here
he's he's the prime sponsor on this uh
but it was not addressed in criminal
justice i i had
during my testimony for example i had a
very
heated is the wrong word i had a very
engaged back and forth uh with
uh the person i view as justice lynn
former justice lynn now representative
lin
he did not have a problem with that
provision
he was very comfortable with that that
provision so
so that's part one
part two
um
i i think uh
594a5
has to be read
uh
[Music]
in the context of 594 a6
which says it it talks about overcoming
the presumption i don't think uh 595 a5
lines 23 for 27 can be read without also
thinking about uh the following uh
provision 595
uh 594a colon six
where it says the presumption of
inadmissibility of statements provided
in a5 may be overcome
um and any statements that were not
electronically recorded may be admitted
if the court fines
etc
um so i i that's that's where that
flexibility comes into place and it i
think it i believe and uh i
welcome uh further questions from
representative leishman or mooney or or
the chair i believe that takes care of
the concern
that if you read a5 independent of a6 i
would have also
i mean i i don't
uh i don't want um i don't want this to
be a richard bill i i was very involved
uh with uh representative uh welch in
drafting this bill and the goal was to
make this
put some flexibility in there
and i think that does it
okay
comments
i'm just going to add thank you for that
and i would make mention i would amend
that section a5
reference then a6 to avoid the trap we
just fell down
i mean i i have no problem at reading uh
a5 reading except this provided in rsa
a colon 4 and rsa 594 colon a6 if it's
that language we're adding in there i
i'm completely comfortable with that not
that my comfort matters keep us out of
the pit
and mr chairman just quickly a gentleman
from the audience would like to comment
as well at your discretion
thank you mr chair my name is john sonia
i'm a lieutenant with the new hampshire
state police i am the commander of the
homicide bureau my last name is spelled
s-o-n-i-a
and uh just listen to the testimony of
professor sheer
i was a little concerned as you pointed
out mr chair but i do agree with
representative mooney that
a fix like that would probably be
necessary to to reference that next area
in the statute i appreciate you
referencing the doj i think it's more
applicable that they speak on
this is a lot of legislation it's two
pages full of amendment and even when i
read it this morning as professor shear
just did it becomes complex especially
if you're doing it for the first time as
he just indicated so it's
it's i think some examination is
appropriate as as you did on this
committee um what that means if that
means again coming back friday and
asking doj to send a representative i
think it's it's not only important to
make sure that it doesn't conflict with
itself but it doesn't also conflict with
other statutes and laws i know that some
of the first testimony brought by uh now
major ebert was it could conflict with
uh some of the one-party statute uh laws
also so it's important with legislation
this long and this
um
this wordy that it i guess the legal
scholars do have input on it and maybe
come in to testify before you uh
presenting that so
any i could take any questions from the
committee that they might have also um
again i just read it this morning also
as a fill-in so but that was part of
just listening to testimony i appreciate
that
i think it should be amended to address
uh right kind of forward look
any other questions
oh i think john's got a great idea
because i look at um
line 30 on page two and then we were
using the word may be admitted again so
i'd really like to hear from the justice
department and
because i still share the concerns that
you have mr chairman okay
but overall our homicide unit does
practice utilizing at least audio
recordings so we feel in the last few
years we've been at the forefront of
this i think it is important um to
really button this up so it can be
utilized in the future but not be
limiting because some language was
missed in there okay
thank you thank you mr chair
now i'm going to lift the hood on the
car
for another issue
that is
this appears to be
a um
downshift
piece of legislation
that we're requiring
uh recordings
i mean at least when you when you start
reading it sounds like here's what
you're going to do
and if there's an associated cost with
that
then we get the downshifting
problem
i would suggest that we change this to
be an enabling
legislation that says if you're going to
do recording
this applies
if your
municipality town
elects not to do a recording
it doesn't apply
so that we're not forcing recordings
thoughts from anybody
representative i appreciate your point
but as pointed out
i think
most
or proponents of individuals who take
confessions have access to some sort of
recording device without an additional
purchase by any
um
sub-political division of the state i
mean
and to have this optional
in my mind would bring us back to right
where we are right now
and why even bother doing it if it's
optional in my
mind but um i could be wrong but that's
i think correcting the language so it's
clear
and understandable i think would
probably be the best approach okay thank
you
any other thoughts
yes sir
thank you mr chair if i may um because
the our homicide unit travels throughout
the state um the the point is well taken
that there are some departments that are
very small and and even though we can
make the assumption has been stated in
testimony it doesn't cost them a lot
it's easy to do
it may not be it may not be in in uh
colebrook new hampshire where we've been
on cases um because their resources are
much more limited
along with the same conversation about
making sure the language is correct and
it it kind of covers all the bases and
not jumping forward too quickly
it might be one you know take into
account like we had mentioned we all
seem to have cell phones nowadays we
have more ability to record than ever
before personally however
when we talk about the recordings for
criminal cases in court that that is
evidence it becomes evidence
we get issued digital recorders in our
unit
so each detective homicide detective can
take that with them anywhere they go
that availability isn't everywhere but
it's also evidence you're recording
criminal evidence on that device and
then you're producing it to court later
so another concern might be to button up
the language because
uh small departments that may not have
policies and procedures as the state
police do
you know we're able to take that medium
copy it to a disk a thumb drive pass it
on
memorialize it as evidence and then pass
it forward to prosecution maintaining
that chain of custody not everyone has
that and we certainly might want to
button up the language so we're not
having local police departments just
utilize their personal cell phone that
could be
come evidenced in a criminal case later
on um or examined for that purpose um so
there there is maybe more thought
process to go into legislation to talk
about policies procedures for the
overall new hampshire law enforcement
community as far as departments and and
within consideration of their various
size
okay any questions for me on that
go ahead
thanks john
uh
it would appear to me and again you've
been doing this a long time but having
recordings of interrogations or whatever
is probably more beneficial
to the department to prove perhaps what
was said or going on versus just
some written statement that someone
could challenge later absolutely yeah
thanks
justice we we and public safety we
talked about the
uh the issue of chain of custody and
[Music]
again
a good part of that was with
i'm going to call him representative
justice lynn
and
i think the general feeling was
when you make policy changes
when you want to make policy changes
it is not a sufficient reason that
police departments will have to develop
new policies not to make the policy
change i mean i think
change to some extent to the extent this
is a change it's not a dramatic one
means some police departments may have
to develop certain policies but you know
the state police has a policy on this uh
some other portsmouth uh of which i'm
quite familiar has a policy on this you
know that they can they can import those
policies from other departments so i
don't think that the concern about
policy change uh at the department by
department level is is one that gets in
the way of this
uh and second uh you know i
uh
we can talk about this forever which i
hope not to in spite of being a law
professor um but
it um
it's not going to cost money we're not
done shifting costs
we just aren't
um you know
it's if
if a officer in a very small department
records it on his personal iphone he can
very quickly send that to the prosecutor
in the case and that's not going to be a
chain of custody i i
um i i teach a course called evidence
which among other things i teach
students about the rules surrounding
chain of custody and getting things into
into court
and that procedure i just described will
be sufficient
you don't have to document every step
you just have to have the officer come
into court when the recording is played
and say yup this is i listened to that
recording just before i came into court
and that's what that person said and
this is a recording of what that person
said
that will take care of the chain of
custody uh circumstance so it's
it's uh
and we don't want to try to legislate
at a statutory level chain of custody
issues that really don't exist or to
legislate what policies individual
departments have to deal with audio or
audio visual recordings i think that's
exactly what
what police departments uh do
all the time they develop policy and
they they share amongst each other uh
policy changes so i think that's um
you know i think this is good
legislation and i think
uh cost wise there's going to be no
burden on on police departments and
policy-wise it's a it's a relatively
minor
uh adaptation on their part
hopefully
hopefully john that doesn't have a
response so i don't have to get back up
again
we need you to use a microphone so
anybody watching the video can
and i wouldn't normally i
again present professor shear i
appreciate that you just said it just
you keep using the word no cost no cost
no cost i guess
there is a cost to somebody and there
are some police departments that make
them purses their own firearms and as we
know farms for a handgun is
is not astronomical three four hundred
dollars all i'm saying is there are
departments that have very low funding
in the state i go throughout the state
so i just every time the word no cost is
repeated it's a cost to somebody just
that consideration is all i'm asking and
i know we talked about evidence a little
bit my point being that if you
if you mandate our police chief mandates
we'll just use your own personal cell
phone again that's a downshifting across
to somebody it may not feel like it but
you're putting on that officer to now
utilize something he pays for to do a
recording for his job to comply with the
law that so that i just wanted to add
that to the conversation
okay thank you
thank you
yes sir yeah thank you for your
testimony i have a question if an
officer uses his personal weapon as well
as his personal
phone isn't that a liability issue on
the department not for the department
the department's going to have that
training they're going to
take him and get him certified on that
weapon to utilize it now if he utilizes
it in the course of his duties that
weapon is probably going to be taken as
evidence can be seized by my unit of the
state police that does officer involved
shootings and they may not see it until
it's adjudicated
so you would lose the weapon and you'd
have to theoretically go buy a new
weapon but it wouldn't it wouldn't
impede the system it's just something
that they allow their office to do and
then they'll go to the range and get
certified on it per police standards and
training councils criteria
okay thank you for that clarification
you're welcome sir
other questions or comments about the
bill
yeah i mean i i
appreciate the point of it will cost
somebody something and i probably don't
want to give up my iphone for evidence
and lose it for a while but um on amazon
i just looked up real quick you can buy
a little recording device for 29
just that would be adequate for
something like that so there there could
possibly be a cost but uh cost benefit
i'm not sure um
we're there thank you well
my point was that we're financed
and i was trying to see
what effect this has financially and
that's the only place that i saw was was
the potential downshifting yes
yeah i agree with you mr chairman
because again if you look going back to
page two and line six
these interrogations at a jail police a
sheriff's station holding sell
correctional or detentional facility
those are all costs
someone's going to have to bear those
whether you know
at a detentional facility do they have
that capability now
i assume the department of corrections
does but i don't know but there's
definitely a cost here in my opinion
well that's that's why i said that we
do we neuter the bill if we make it
enabling legislation
and basically leaves us where we are
right now to representative hatch's
point
uh or do we want to have
an
idea that we're trying to affect
policing in the state
yes
thank you so just to get back to your
thought about an enabling legislation
piece an exception almost for the small
departments that officer sonia
referenced would you be adding a section
roman 3
on page 2 to a4 because there is an
exception provision
so despite all this very harsh you know
shells
alls and ease and so forth throughout
there is a large exception
section
that could um with the right language
make
provisions for the departments that may
not have
the funds to record what line was that
again
line 35
no
i was actually referring to
page 2
adding it
between line
lines 22 and 23
so it would be part of the a4 exception
section which is headed on line 11 of
page two
well i was thinking that if we were to
add a roman 3 to a4
which starts on line 11 section 84
starts on line 11.
if we were to add a roman 3 that would
address the financial exception almost
like a financial exception provision
yeah
so the financial
upset
i'll get it out in a minute
exception would be if you can't afford
it that this doesn't apply
right
yeah
that
that that's fine that's then it's not
right
yeah
yes sir
under under um
a6
i think the financial
circumstances of you know if it's if
it's the uh
freedom new hampshire
police department
um and uh there's nobody there who has
a a
an i a cell phone they don't have any
kind of uh tape recorder they don't have
any kind of audio visual equipment
i think they fit under the uh
the under a6 in terms of ways
explanations for them not having
uh
not being able to record it i think that
that is that is the point of that
exceptional we don't want to make this
so rigid that in the circumstances i
just described in a freedom new
hampshire police department we don't
want to make it so rigid that that
exception can't be that kind of
explanation
uh the the reason we had the broad a6 is
we can
because
this is an ambiguous flattery because
they're all smart people
um you know we can we don't want to be a
circumstance where we all come up with
yet another exception we need to add
once you start adding exception after
exception after exception for individual
circumstances i mean you're i'm sure
more familiar than i am what a mass
legislation turns into when you do that
that's the point of asics you know we're
going to leave it to judges if if it's
one of those departments i don't you
know
i used to have practiced in front of
every superior court judge but i'm so
old now that most of them are retired
although some of them are now my
students that's how old i am um
you know i i can't imagine a judge in
the circumstance i described not saying
you you've overcome the presumption and
that we're going to admit this we we
don't want a circumstance where a very
small police department uh loses a case
and a victim
uh
doesn't get the kind of justice that
they're owed simply because of that and
that's why that exception is there it's
intentionally
broad because we want to leave it to
judges informed by prosecutors informed
by defense lawyers informed by
lawyers for the victims we want to leave
it to judges to
figure out
is it a is it a reasonable exception
so
thank you yes hopefully i can keep
remembering john quiet representative
goalie
thank you mr chair i just i'm glad he's
pointing out that section because in
reading it
part of uh a6 states that for purposes
of this statute mere inconvenience or
financial expense shall not be
considered reasonable justification
so i'm reading that to say that they
shall expend the money to get the
equipment because that will not be
reasonable
yeah
i i think yes and no they don't uh if if
they've deci if they've made a conscious
decision not to spend the money that's
one thing but if it's a circumstance
that the only member of the department
who has the tape recorder or it's being
used in another circumstance
or the only member of the department who
has a cell phone is not there and it's
three in the morning
then i i don't think
that is
uh that's what that contemplates that
that said
um
yes you know
it's possible
that there is a police department out
there
um and
that doesn't have
the basic tape recorder
i don't know of anyone that does
that that you know does not have a
physical tape recorder and and i think
in the theory of this being a
downshifting of a cost is there i i
appreciate that
uh but in reality i just don't think
it's it's very very unlikely that it's
there and as representative hatch put
pointed out it's very very simple uh and
if we're downshifting the cost of 50
bucks
to the smaller police departments in
return for the greater impetus behind
this legislation that is
we want to have some more protection
within reason we want to have some more
protection about against the possibility
of false confessions
uh and balance that against some smaller
police departments will have to spend 50
more dollars i mean you know that
that's the consideration that i want all
of you to make and i i appreciate all
your concerns
yes
one more cycle
couldn't i couldn't do it
thank you
based on what everyone was just talking
about now
i do agree with the point over here
about um when you read that it does
limit it um and i again i i appreciate
professor shir mentioning that it's kind
of nice to leave these up to the judge
is it is there a way to make
mere inconvenience shall not be
considered reasonable
however financial expense would be up to
a judge to determine if that was
reasonable i guess that the limiting
language of
you're putting in here shall not you're
you're saying it the judge is going to
read this and say well i can't do
anything with that
but again if we allow the court system
to be the court system and and you know
weigh things uh
in in different areas maybe
a change in the language would be
beneficial for that reason to kind of
tighten that up and allow the court to
decide
representative gold do you have any
thoughts on that one
the the only other
concern i mean we
there's continuation continue to talk
about just
voice recordings but if you look on page
two
uh lines three through
seven
if they are
in a custodial interrogation at a jail
police or sheriff's station holding cell
or correction or detention facility
shall be recorded by audio and video
so it's not just a tape recorder
oh
not or whether
so if it said or it would work better
than and
in agreement with that part of the
limiting language is it it's talking
about the whole facility so i would
imagine that the department of
corrections or the the county jail
system would probably say
that would be a huge cost to them
because they'd have to
have that ability to audio and video
record every portion of their facility
not knowing when you're going to have uh
some some kind of uh
custodial questioning take
place yes representative griffin
i thank you mr chair
for the purposes of the statue of mary
and convenience of financial extension
what happens if we just delete that
sentence
and we rely on
the law and the reasonableness of it
i'm i'm comfortable uh with uh the uh
amendment that
uh
uh john suggested uh on in terms of the
financial circumstances or uh
representative griffin's and and i'm i'm
certainly
uh comfortable with making the and and
or
um as before and i'm willing um for for
what it's worth um
i'm willing to incorporate all that
we've talked about uh
into
an amendment and offer it and send it to
uh the chair and members of the
committee just for drafting purposes if
if that's appropriate i don't need to
but
okay
i can't be here on friday i am in
washington dc learning how to build
police stations oh it sounds
enlightening
[Laughter]
your point is noted
so online on line seven if it end if it
ended shall be recorded period
then we can go back to the definition of
what recordings are
yep
is that is that acceptable
okay
now as far as line what was the jury 37
yeah the the sentences starts at the end
of line 36
and goes to through 37.
if we just delete that then we're back
to the uh
594 a
six or four or whatever it is that
doe talks about the reasonableness of
the fund right so then if then there's
the judge is not looking at this as an
instruction at that point
um and and would representative griffin
how would you feel about
that language uh uh
or financial circumstances unless uh
unless the judge were to rule um
well actually i'm trying to build in a a
mechanism for the judge too i'm just
concerned that that some departments are
just going to say
all right we don't have to do this
because we don't want to pay the money
um and and it's 50 bucks i mean that's
my concern so i'd like i'd like a a
judge to have an opportunity to evaluate
whether you know
whether the financial circumstances are
legitimate you know uh that's i guess
that's my only hesitation on what
representative griffin is talking about
um i you know i
i've probably i've been a lawyer too
long i say you know too much
that's what that's what my students say
yes jerry it seems to me like you made a
good case about uh 594 a6 i believe it
is yeah
that it leads a lot to the judge
and my problem with the last sentence on
page two is that
it takes it away from the judge if we
just get rid of the sentence
then we're back to
some flexibility
i'm fine with that
mike are you taking notes
okay just one suggestion representative
so
to representative griffin's point
line 36
what if it
read
of the surrounding facts and
circumstances explaining the lack of
recording which may include
financial expense
here now the judge would
have at least some direction and an
example
for why there wasn't a recording and
that may include the financial expense
piece
does that work i certainly wouldn't have
a problem with that and you would put
that at the end of the prior sentence
end of the first sentence uh the end of
line 36
so in other words
uh it would read of the surrounding
facts and circumstances explaining the
lack of a recording which may include
financial expense
and then delete the very last line of
the bill starting with the words for
purposes of this
my only suggestion would be to delete
out of that last line or financial
expense i i i i
i'm a little hesitant to delete
inconvenience
if if that's appropriate
i mean i i think given what you
suggested
uh uh earlier um you know adding which
may include financial expense i think we
can delete or financial expense from
that last sentence but leave in the word
inconvenience yeah that i that makes
sense
because
looking at this from 30 000 feet it
looks like what we're trying to do is
codify best practices yep
so
i think that just did it
i will i will uh ideally i will get this
to the chair later this afternoon okay
to the members of the committee
no
we'll we'll take care of the you'll take
oh yeah we'll we'll redraft this okay
and we'll get you a copy i appreciate
that and somebody else uh either from
the national instance project or uh
somebody local from the local new
england instance project will be here on
friday
while i
figure out how not to spend money and
still build a new police station okay
thank you thank you mr shearer
yes mr hoffman
okay
i believe on page two line seven
ends
uh
shall be recorded period
uh then uh page 2 line
lack of recording which may include
financial expense
be added to the
first sentence
second sentence stays as is with the
exception of or financial expense is
deleted
so it says
mere inconvenience shall not be
considered
so the inconvenience is left in but the
the uh or financial expense is deleted
yes
one morning
thank you and then
one additional
to that list all right if we're in
agreement is line 27
to make reference to section a6 it was
the earliest of the conversations
related to an amendment
so it was close including a6 and a5
yes that works
it gets it up front and so yeah
okay any other comments
see the ones i thought were going to fly
through were bogging down
okay
well it just got longer okay so
all right so that
uh 50 i'm gonna 1540 is in recess until
one o'clock on friday
okay
i hope we got some simple ones here
yes sir certainly
mr hoffman good turning back are we
still alive
did you check please
thank you
uh yes
we're still live okay
i would open the uh work session on
house bill 1647
relative to calculation of child support
does anybody have any comments that we'd
like to make on this bill
members the committee any
emails phone calls that
would
sidetrack this in any way because as i
read through this i certainly have no
expertise in this one
yes representative mooney
thank you mr chairman i would just like
to point out that last evening
a relatively very
detailed email came in related to this
bill
it looks like it's from the what's
called the child support working group
with a membership list that was below
including a mary krueger aaron
jaszina
bill woodbury
honey hastings anthony matt
malo
sorry if i mispronounced the name
and
quite a bit of information here it did
come relatively in last night it would
be good to talk to someone from the
children and family law committee if
they were present but
other than that
i um
let's see this would be interested in
hearing more this this came out of
committee otp 8 to 7.
yes mr representative griffin
um i think our job is is more of the
financial cost of this bill and
it seems to be
indeterminable
and
so that's my question is
what what would the financial cost of
the state be
i suspect a lot of that would be u.s
government money
if if in fact there is a cost
and
hopefully the policy committee
has received the information that you
have received
and has looked at it
yeah i have to look at this one and say
the policy committee to me trump's
any idea i would have because i have
nothing to contribute to this mr hoffman
anybody like to comment on this
legislation
morning
i'm susan brisson i'm the the chief
staff attorney for the department of
health and human services uh bureau of
child support
and also with me is lisa decatowski okay
could you re repeat your name sure
slowly please susan brisson that's
b-r-i-s-s-o-n
okay got it thank you you're welcome
the department doesn't take a position
on this this bill but we
could address some of the issues with
regards to cost we did do a uh a fiscal
note for it
um
i think our our biggest concern
is um
when you start well first it
changes the self-support reserve from
of uh the poverty level to up to 150
percent which is going to result in more
minimum orders for child support which
could then
result in
families receiving public assistance so
less less child support more public
assistance which would then be a cost
it's unclear to know you know how many
of those cases would happen but it
that's that's our first concern
what's your second concern
um
well the second concern has is is making
sure it has language with regards to uh
that the change in the law is not then a
reason for
uh the parties to come to court to
change their child support order
uh because that would be a basically a
run on the court
expenses to the court expenses expenses
to the department
that's kind of sort of just a technical
so should there be language in here that
addresses that
there should be i
i forgive me there are several well
three separate child support
type builds right now so which which one
has which language is uh kind of modeled
but
we are making sure that that that that
gets handled okay
questions from the committee yes
representative
thanks mr chairman
so your department do you see any
additional staff required because the
judicial branch says there'll be more
time needed for judges case
workers marital masters that type of
thing
let's see what else
because of the increased amount of work
for the judicial branch i would assume
they may have some cause they said
they're indeterminable but do you see a
need of hiring additional staff at the
department your department
i mean i don't
we haven't had those concerns um
it's it's more the the issue of time
which could lead to more
the need for more staff but it might
just be a delay in
all cases if each case takes longer
things just sort of get pushed pushed
down the road a bit
this
these guidelines are very
are turning in
our current guidelines are making them a
lot more complicated
um
they're
similar to what's going on in the state
of vermont right right now
and it's just longer more complicated
obviously we'll get better at it as we
go but um
it's
more discussion about
uh parenting time will then
um
result in having then because the time
will then
go into
for how many nights
what's the analysis and uh
that that type of thing
just oh i'm sorry i'm sorry just a quick
follow-up mr chairman
so your response concerns me because we
both know we all know here that the
department
is uh hundreds and hundreds of employees
short
now so
by saying this was going to add more of
a burden it's going gonna delay things
that's that would be a huge concern of
mine and probably shared by everybody
here
i mean i would say it's a concern what
the what the level of it is is is always
is always the question um it's unclear
to me um
how many actual what the actual change
will be
because we the cases we deal with
there's sort of a range
of people we deal with people who don't
even
we have child support orders that don't
have parenting
um orders themselves they just
deal with it they either get along or
they don't get along but they don't have
you know court-ordered parenting
so we're we're uh
that's where i sort of look at these and
go okay well how are we gonna deal with
that
um
because of the issues of uh
he says i've got the kids you know five
nights a week and she says no i've got
the kids five nights a week i'm not sure
um at least my office you know that's
then we have a hearing um which is
probably where the
the court is looking at
you know more hearings but
mr representative patch
i just uh i need to be caught up because
um when you're saying parenting you're
talking about
amount of time for custody for each
custodial parent is that correct the the
term custody is not something that we
use right well whatever just so i
understand it thank you for your
tolerance
um
so
uh
what
who adjudicates the fact that when
um
the non-custodial parent
doesn't
pay their fair share or however you want
to say that that goes to the courts
correct correct there go the need for
more uh judicial staff or whatever in
the courts
but that again you're saying that will
not
have any effect on your workload to the
point that
uh additional staff may be needed
because um i i would think there's a
correlation between the two
if i may that's
what i'm trying to well i unless i don't
understand what's going on other than i
know my bride
counsels many young ladies who are
without a husband
home
and don't get any support and very
little help in
achieving that but that's neither here
nor there so
right um
child support has two
big areas that we sort of divide into um
establishment and then enforcement
and this bill i think
lands in the is the establishment realm
and it's what should child support be
then once there's an order
whatever the number is
then we run into
um
enforcement
and that's a different sort of a
different area that i'm not sure this
bill would affect that much
um because the the the order has to be
enforced whether it's you know 50 a
month or
500 a month
um
sure
representative griffin
thank you mr chair
i wonder if i could ask you to monetize
you said there would be a cost
is it a thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars a million dollars 10
million dollars
what what do you estimate the cost may
be of this bill
i i i don't have the skills to be able
to to be able to do that unfortunately
um and as a follow-up uh of course i may
uh who would pay that cost
well i think we've already had some
discussion that i mean if it's if it's
more hearings that's
from the department that's definitely
the court
um
if the parties have to come to court
more if there are more hearings
they have their sort of assigned costs i
was again i'm sort of speculating we
don't deal with cases that have too many
attorneys on the other side it's usually
us
and then the parties are unrepresented
but if this gets incredibly complicated
like it sounds like it could
um
there might be more people who need
attorneys and they'll end up having to
to to deal with that cost as well
to have a an attorney help them walk
through that process
thank you for your testimony
any other questions
thanks mr chairman
so could you tell me what this
self-support reserve is and where does
that money come from
the self-support reserve is a number
that's based on the poverty level which
is set by the federal government
and it's it's not a it's not a figure
that's paid it's a figure that's used
when calculating child support and it's
supposed to represent
what the person who pays child support
gets to keep for themselves in the first
instance to
for their own
very basic needs like right now it's
easy to remember because it's 1 234
so in the math
at a certain point you
when you get down to income that's
available to pay support you subtract
out the self-support reserve
that income would which is reserved for
the payor and then anything that left
that's left over
is what child support would come out of
okay
thanks thanks mr so that's and that's
per month correct okay
it's it'll be it's due to be reset in
april
every every april the the the new
guidelines are set
and the self-support reserve
goes up generally a little bit okay mr
hoffman do you have a question
well
regarding the
possible run on the courts
the bill is amended has
okay good yeah um
page four
[Music]
starting at line 25 it's got the
language that this act shall not
constitute a substantial change in
circumstances for the purposes of 458 c7
which is the modification language so
basically it says that
that just because this law has changed
that is not a reason
to revisit it to revisit it you can't go
in and say the law has changed i want a
new a new child supporter there has to
be a separate reason okay
um so that's
that's very um
helpful on that on that we won't have
piling on
we would hope not okay oh
other questions
thank you very much thank you
excuse i have i have a question um
what is your correct title for the
record please
chief staff attorney
thank you very much you're welcome
anyone else like to comment on this
seeing them what's the pleasure of the
committee
or the division i should say
not all at once
i haven't got a clue
yes okay yeah um
yeah mr chairman i'm just kind of
curious that
this almost seems like a division three
issue yeah and maybe run it by them
first
a lot of this is uh
we generally don't deal with it as you
know the department of health and human
services so i think it ended up first
because of the judiciary yeah maybe
i know we're a difficult lot over here
and pretty thorough but i just
a lot of questions came up again from
the
chief staff attorney for the department
of health and human services that maybe
well as much as i don't want to we will
recess this until friday at one and try
to get some reading from division three
good thanks ah
yeah put it on the bus
this should be an easy one
you said that before
1496 requiring physical subdivisions to
make motor vehicle
checklists
voter i'm sorry voter checklist
available in spreadsheet this is saying
that they can give the
voter checklist out in electronic form
instead of printed copy
i certainly hope we can all agree that's
not a
a problem
mr chair i would move ought to pass oh
my gosh house bill
1496 ought to pass otp
let's call a roll and because i
hopefully we're going to get one through
hold on
a march motion is not the pass right
yeah how to pass
i'm all set
all right if you're on paper you'll vote
in the affirmative if not you'll vote on
the negative that being said
mr chairman yes
uh vice chairman yes clark folks yes
yes
representative
goalie yes
it's unanimous
okay that being done i will close the
the work session on 1496
and i would open the work session on
uh house bill 1552 which is the last
bill under consideration
today establishing a board for
certification of assessors
does anybody on the committee have any
comments
or does anybody here have any comments
please
good morning
mr chair members of the division for the
record lindsey courtney executive
director office of professional lease
insurance certification
courtney c-o-u-r-t anyway
thank you
so oplc does not take a position on this
bill um we provide administrative
support to
over 54 licensing boards so this would
add another one
and i think there's some legislation in
the works that would also
bring the boxing commission over to
oplc this
session
what's that and horse racing
we don't have that yet so i'm sure
that'll come up soon um
i just wanted to um
to provide some observations and to the
division because there are some pending
legislative changes that i think could
impact this bill if it were to be passed
the first would be there's a recent
amendment to senate bill 330
and in the bill it
would recognize that licensure
can have an impact on workforce and that
would establish a study committee to
determine
how we license and certify individuals
in this state obviously that would take
some time but presumably any findings
that come out of that study could impact
if this bill were to go forward so i
wanted to let the division know about
that one
and there's also
it's my understanding and amendment that
may go forward to senate bill 313
specific to funding
there have been a lot of discussions
among stakeholders about the appropriate
way to fund the office
who should determine fees how fees
should be allocated
right now
the office has currently has statutory
authority over
most of professions in terms of setting
fees
but we know being on jail card that the
boards have retained some of that
authority so
this
amendment to senate bill 313 would
establish a study committee
what came out out of conversations
to senate bill 313 as introduced was
that there are disputes among
stakeholders as to what the mechanism
for funding the agency should be
there are challenges
when you seek to
require that the licensee
that the agency be completely
self-supporting and if the cost
allocation is based on
um
a consistent uh
consistent licensure fee that there are
certain individuals who may not be able
to pay
um their fair share so to speak so
this committee would look at that there
have been suggestions that maybe we move
away from self-funding the agency i
don't think that would go very far
that's my personal opinion but that
obviously um that report could impact i
think what would happen with this board
as
it relates to funding you i think saw
the fiscal note
we assumed that this would be a
completely self-funded board like the
other boards
the average
cost of shared services
for a license and oplc is 155 dollars
for two years so that would be what we
would propose
that the certification fee should be
we don't know how many individuals are
actually licensed
we also don't know how much support
would be required
we classify all of our boards based on
identifiers
that we worked with the division of
personnel on into a b and c boards
depending on how much support they need
my assumption is that they would fall in
the middle like the real estate
appraiser so they would have a dedicated
board administrator um and maybe a
licensed clerk but until
until we um start working with the board
to determine the complexity it's it's
not clear how much would be needed in
terms of staff support but any event i'd
i'd be happy to answer any questions
that you may have i appreciate the
opportunity
representative griffin
thank you mr chair
my question is
having served as a selectmen in a fairly
small town
we were the board of assessors who would
this
bill affect would it affect
professionals only outside people who
who
charge for their service
or would it affect
staff or in a city and down level
so i'm going to defer to the department
dre on that because i'm not intimately
familiar yet with the assessors
my understanding it would be just
certification of the professionals only
that's correct
thank you okay
other questions yes representation
thanks mr chairman uh thanks for
appearing
uh
i didn't see in here that this may go
back some time but there's a portion or
a couple of areas i'm like for instance
on page six line five as far as the
assessing of fines and violations
is there an appeals process for that
because i didn't happen to see it but i
may have overlooked it but i was just
curious if you
assess a two thousand dollar fine is
that appealable to somebody yeah so that
would be considered disciplinary so one
is entitled to due process a notice and
an opportunity to be heard most
we did seek a legislative change last
year
that did get passed
so all appeals
go to the supreme court
and
some of the board i think one board had
a mechanism to go to superior court and
then go to supreme court it didn't make
sense to us that you you would have to
go through a couple of different steps
um i will say though that that's you
know
from a policy
standpoint that's that can be concerning
because who's going to spend twenty
thousand dollars on an appeal to appeal
a thousand dollar fine so you know the
state may want to look at that when um
when you know if there were to be a
study committee on occupational
licensing
because i can tell you that it's usually
only physicians you know a handful of
you know maybe dentists who actually
appeal
um decisions of a licensing board
a follow-up if i could mr chairman
so we're looking at assessment and as
representative griffin pointed out
um
bringing the dra into the picture now
the dra has a procedure for appealing
assessments and then they have an
internal body and that can go to the
board of tax and land appeal so i guess
what i'm hoping is that somewhere down
the line you do something internally so
somebody doesn't have to go to superior
court and then the final question if i
could mr chairman
so it says that you have all these
powers
uh for instance um
to administer ults and affirm uh
affirmations uh
subpoenas witnesses compel
people by subpoenas
what
uh is there statutorily something that
um
what am i looking for like your
credentials for hiring at this job do
you have to be an attorney or
hold it justice of the peace or
because you've got pretty broad powers
um
it's not required so i'm appointed by
the governor and approved my counsel i
am both a jp and an attorney
um but i will say this statute i think
is crafted off of first of all i don't
take a position on whether i should have
this powers or i didn't craft this
statute but i think it's based on the
real estate appraisers um
and i will say it's very common for
state statutes to delegate authority to
a commissioner or an agency head it's
not actually that person who
historically carries out all functions
if you look at you know commissioner of
hhs for example if you look at the ddj
statute that there's a lot of
requirements that the commissioner do x
y and z
that's usually delegated either via rule
rule and policy and procedure after
internal controls are established so
so this would typically be done pursuant
to as a particular rule and procedure
okay i just had never seen that mr
chairman it kind of caught my eye that
the not you know putting you on the spot
but the position has those
immense powers right
another oh yes representative goalie
thank you mr chair and sitting on edna
we deal with all the licensing
certification and
registration bills um
and this did come to the committee 18 to
zero with these recommendations because
of what we heard from
revenue administration and transferring
these folks over only made sense to put
them in their own board in a separate
statute under oplc
so that's the problem this is solving
i'll defer the department on that
good one
my name is
sorry my name is carolyn lear l-e-a-r
and i am the assistant commissioner at
the department of revenue
um
so i would say um from the department
the department doesn't take a position
on this bill and i would say from the
department's perspective there actually
isn't an issue
to be solved here
um this was a bill i believe
that was requested by the assessing
community
based on a recommendation from the
assessing standards board which is an
administratively attached board to the
department but is not
the department
so the commissioner has one seat of i
think
12 seats on that board but it's
primarily made up of either
professional assessors or local
assessing officials
the
rule framework for assessor
certification is also
from that board and the department
really just administers those rules as
it relates to the certification process
for assessors
which we are happy to continue doing i
wish there were assessors here today to
tell you why they thought it was um
necessary to transition the board from
the department of revenue to oplc
to summarize what i understand their
concerns to be
without you know speaking for them
formally
the department of revenue has a pretty
ironclad confidentiality statute
that makes
most of what we do at the department
confidential
and my understanding is that the
assessors are dissatisfied that
the certification and specifically the
assessor discipline process
when complaints are brought against
assessors falls within that
confidentiality umbrella
and they propose to fix that with this
transition of the certification function
from the department of revenue to oplc
that being said there is another bill
making its way through the process
senate bill 53
holdover from last session which should
be crossing over to you that takes a
more direct route and makes assessor
certification records public so rather
than transition the board entirely to
oplc it would simply make um
those records public and available for
the public to see much like a real
estate license
you can go online and see if somebody
has a real estate yep
okay
so this
i'm starting to understand
so what this bill does is basically move
the assessor's functionality supervision
whatever over to oplc from
dra that's exactly right
so we're really not changing anything
we're just
moving it over
there are some substantive changes to
the makeup of the certification board
as i had mentioned
the assessing standards board which sets
the rules for assessor certification has
about a dozen members
intended to represent both large towns
and small towns
municipalities as well as taxpayers
the commissioner has a seat on that
board as well as several legislators the
makeup of this board before oplc is much
smaller
and therefore represents fewer of those
interested parties in its makeup
hmm
it was cut and dry before but now it
gets confusing yes
representative griffin go ahead nope
i'll speak to it after okay go ahead
representative lishman
thanks mr chairman so i appreciate you
saying that you're not taking a position
but
reading that between the lines it kind
of sounds like
the dra
isn't entirely happy with this
legislation
i wouldn't say that no i would i would
say
that um
property taxes
make up a huge proportion of the tax
burden in the state of new hampshire
and
the assessors the certified assessors
that value
property
have a hugely important role in ensuring
the fairness of that process
so i wouldn't say that we're opposed to
to moving them to a different agency but
i think it should be a very carefully
thought out decision to do so
so that those interests continue to be
protected
you know if i could um mr chairman
so i've sat here a long time and seen a
number of dre commissioners and it's
always been the greatest respect and
you folks do a good job and like i
mentioned earlier there's an appeals
process within the
agency within a certain bureau and they
work well with taxpayers so i guess
gut feeling is
i think the dre has done a good job
overseeing assessing in the state and
appraisals we recently had a problem in
peterborough and the department sent
people down to talk with taxpayers so
i'm just a little concerned of
tearing that oversight away if you will
and giving it to the oplc that's my
concern
i have that thought as well and i'm
pretty familiar with the oplc
being on dell car for many years and
adjudicating their rules and i'm very
comfortable with the current
structure of the oplc but then again
going to my concern i don't know if the
same structure
exists within the oplc
to adjudicate some of these
concerns with
[Music]
assessment values
like the dra currently does i mean the
oplc handles physicians i mean they
handle a myriad of very important
functions they handle a wide range of
subjects and do a very good job at it
within the boards they oversee what we
need to understand is the oplc all they
do do
are supposed to do it's a consolidation
of different boards and handle the
administrative functions of a myriad of
boards
and i don't know if within the oplc
that they have the wherewithal
and the
uninterested party to adjudicate some
assessment
assessment concerns
like we currently have in the dra and
i'm not sure that i
understand enough what the lplc would
incorporate from the dra to have that
same
adjudicative body with the expertise
that the dra has
currently so i
i would have to get a lot more
information before i would even but i'm
not a policy guy i just do finance but
this representative this is concerned
thank you mr chair and
once again
i like to think that the edna committee
when we look at these bills and these
boards and certifications do our
diligence when we do it and
my understanding is in doing this the
oplc will be just reviewing the criteria
for the licensing and registration of
these individuals
it will still maintain dras ability to
deal with the assessing standards and
the assessments that go on and anything
that needs to be adjudicated in that
sense the board is not oplc is not
taking over that aspect they are just
taking over
the
licensing procedures and maintaining
those license licensees and taking the
board under their scope of
practice versus dra dra still maintains
all the assessing and any discrepancies
that go on still goes through them and
not through oplc
and if i'm wrong please correct me
representative griffin
thank you mr chair
i'm coming at this from a very different
perspective than everyone else i guess
i look at
both the dra and the and the licensing
board
as being part of the executive
department of the state
and
as such
it seems to me that if there's a need
to make a change it should be coming
from the governor and his staff
instead of from from us as legislators
but over and above that i was very
pleased to hear
that the senate bill
there is a senate bill
that is addressing the major issue here
which seems to be
pushing the bill
forward
and i just hate to see
i hate to see the assessors
pushed over in the licensing board
inevitably
it will raise the cost of hiring
assessor
and it just grows a bureaucracy
and it's part of the executive
department and if the governor
and his managers feel like
they need this bill
they're the ones that should be
be pushing it and sponsoring it and i
don't see that happening
so i plan to vote against
the bill
anyone else
i'll second representative griffin's
motion
ito ido
uh 15 52 hp 1552
okay do you have a second oh you
seconded it okay
this
we're not a couple things here and
that's
part of why i went on my tirade that i
did is we're not a policy committee and
we're voting this down
based on the lack of policy now
understand that the oplc
and
that's my point has taken over
a myriad of very important licenses for
individuals to assure their their they
fall within the compliance of whatever
board
that exists within their auspices
and we're really not changing the way
the earth rotates here all right
all we're changing is ensuring that the
licensure of assessing
individuals that are tasked
given that task
meet
within a certain
standard as decided by their board we're
not changing the way the earth rotates
all we're doing is changing how it
the administration of that and and
probably if
the same thing com
follows as it did with a myriad of other
licenses we have in this state
it will only improve that process
and make it a little better and that's
what has that's what's currently
happening so
i'm not i'm not at all opposed to this
and i trust the policy committee
did their due diligence in an area that
i'm not that familiar with so i i
would i would not vote for uh itl on
this based on that and this came out of
the policy committee 18-0 right yes
representative goalie thank you mr
chairman if i may and being on that
policy committee it did come out 18 to
nothing and was passed on consent
for this policy
one of the other main reasons which you
heard earlier
which
we can talk about a senate bill but we
do not have it in our possession correct
right now
if we don't do anything we still are
going to have that 91a issue that was
talked about earlier this was one of
those ways to address that issue that
was brought before the policy committee
the policy committee reviewed all its
options this bill was amended as you can
see with an amendment to make it better
and
address the concerns that were brought
forward
and therefore went to the house floor as
a unanimous recommendation
so i i can't support itl
after that being said and those votes
being taken from the committee that
their main
focus is dealing with licensure and
that
representation so sticking to this the
financial aspects of this we're creating
an assessing certification board
we're establishing
fines which there is no appeals process
you know looking at the fiscal note i
think there are about 200 individuals
that will be assessed
a fee of 155 dollars so i'm just
there's some there's some costs whereas
creating a board of i don't know how
many different professionals that will
obviously
receive some sort of
pay actual travel by new board members
um
so i guess i stand by my second
even though the there are some financial
implications and the thing that
bothers me about assessing fees and
fines is a process where you don't
give someone
an easy way out to appeal and force them
to go to superior court and that costs
money
okay representative griffin
just to uh
to add to uh representative leachman's
remarks uh
usually when people get in the
professionals get into the licensing
board
the requirements for continuing
professional education
get enacted and they tend to grow over a
period of time
and the costs of those
doubled really
the assessor would have if he's required
for continuing
professional education he'd have the
cost of the education itself
plus he'd have the
week or two weeks
in some cases that he'd lose
to do his job basically so there is a
cost to it it's uh
it's it's
it's kind of a disease that our uh
society suffers from
the more we legislate the more we put
into law
the higher the cost of everything
becomes because there is a cost cause
okay
oh i'm sorry yes
thank you mr chairman i i would state
that
from dra that there is a cost for these
folks currently who are registered and
licensed
without this board being in place that
there's there is a cost for their
certification currently and that if they
do no wrong that there's no recourse and
no fines or
violations for these individuals
yes
so there currently is no fee for the
certification license before the dra
so that would be an increased cost
difference
i tried to quickly look at our rule the
assessing standard board's rules because
those rules do set forth the types of
discipline that can result
i don't believe we can issue fines but i
couldn't quickly get them on my phone my
experience has been
within at the department for the past
just under a decade we have never issued
a fine
the types of discipline that we issue
when there's a
determination that there has been
some sort of assessor wrongdoing is
typically a period of downgraded
certification
license suspension for a period of time
or
education requirements taking classes to
sort of remediate the misunderstanding
that led to the error
i'm not sure if it's that we just have
never issued a fine or if we don't
actually have the ability i couldn't
quickly
locate that in the rules
thank you
go ahead representative okay thank you
given the recent problems we had in
berlin with our assessing board no no i
just wanted to make a comment um i'm not
in favor of itl in this this bill
as a result the dra we disbanded our
assessors
which are important by the judge and the
city council as a result the city
council now acts as the board of
assisters i think this bill is
definitely needed to proceed with doing
some type of
correction to make sure that they're
qualified so i will be voting against
the itl motion
my difficulty with with itl is is a
policy committee coming out 18-0
i have to i have to say that they know a
lot more about this than
than i do certainly
so i would i would have to not support
itl
so with that said there's a motion made
and seconded
you want to call the roll
sure thank you
chairman votes no
the vice chairman yes
the clerk votes no
represent mooney no
represent leichmann
yes
representative patch
represent oh i'm sorry represent goalie
no
okay the motion is uh two to five so the
nay's the motion does not pass okay i'll
make a motion okay ought to pass
all right do we have a second
okay seconded by representative hatch
okay i'm going to call the ought to pass
role okay i will do that okay um
let me do this differently okay the
chairman yes
uh representative griffin
no
the clerk votes yes representative
mooney yes representative leishman no
representative hatch yes
representative goalie yes okay the
motion is five to two in favor about the
past motion okay
with that said
uh
hb 1522 will
go as otp
and that concludes
this
hearing or this worksheet
i usually get it in the mail oh
so representative the burj
all your towns like
your
selectmen act as a board of assessors
see that again
all your towns i've served as a
selectmen for 14 years and you actually
the select board or city council
whatever they serve as a board of
assessors for that community
no right
i don't want to come back
we may not be it's still flashing
friday is the 18th now
what's friday 18th
all yeah
yes
choose which one of them
you